welcome to this tutorial i'm thomas webb
fighter developer from sweden and i'm
back again here on free code camp to
show you how to build
a cool little arkanoid game in
typescript plain vanilla typescript and
as usual i love to create videos for
free code camp
free code camp is great so that's why i
have provided this video for you
and if you don't already know it i have
my own youtube channel that you can
visit for weekly videos
on stuff like this i do a lot of react
gatsby
stuff and also a lot of other javascript
stuff and html css
you name it and i also have a more
premium courses that i have on my site
so all the links for this
is down below and please support me and
visit my channel and subscribe to it if
you like my stuff
and teaching style so nothing more to
say here
let's get started
we're going to build a classic arkanoid
game or
i think it's called crackout or
something also i don't know
but for me it's arkanoid i had a
commodore 64 when i was young and also
an amiga
so it was called arkanoid so this is
some kind of clone of that game that i'm
going to show you how to build
with vanilla typescript no react or
stuff like that
just plain typescript but i'm going to
use the parcel
to make it a little bit easier for us to
create modules and different classes and
stuff
and the game looks something like this
you have this paddle and a ball that
bounces
and you can see that these bricks have
different energies set to them so you
have to hit them
more times depending on what color it is
i think the ones
at the top is gonna have just one energy
level
and the purple blue and yellow are gonna
have i think the yellow one had
two and the blue and purple may have
three or something yeah
so this is the game that we're going to
build and it's going to be super fun i'm
going to create classes and stuff like
that
i'm not going to go all in on
object-oriented programming as
javascript
and typescript isn't meant
to be a fully object-oriented
language but i'm going to show you some
neat stuff in typescript and hopefully
give you some idea on how you can build
a game like this so let's continue on
i'm going to talk a little about the
starter files that
i provided for this tutorial
all right we're going to start to build
this game and the first thing i want you
to do
is to go inside of the starter files
that you hopefully downloaded
and there's a folder inside of there
that's called something like
arkanoid ts start here navigate inside
of that folder
run npm install and then you type in mpm
start
and that will start up your dev
environment so this is how it will look
this won't work now of course but if you
check your console it should console
logout start here
and that's the starter files for this
course and i'm going to go through the
starter files right now so go back to
your code editor
and you can see that i'm inside a folder
here that's called arcanoid.ts
as i said yours is going to be called
the dash start here
if you don't rename it you can of course
rename it to whatever you want
so what we have here is the ts config
file and this is a basic one i haven't
made
any changes to this one because because
you can set up typescript with the
different rules and it's very very
subjective
on how you want it so i want to keep
this to a minimum and we're using parcel
for this course as a bundler
so it will have some default config so
you don't even need to have this ts
config
but in this case i needed it because i'm
going to import some images and stuff so
that's why i have it
then we have the package.json and you
can see here some different stuff here
that i set up i set up
eslint with typescript and i have parcel
and i have prettier and typescript
installed for these ones
so that's what i set up in the starter
files for us so it's essentially a
parcel setup
where i set up typescript and printer
and also set up the linting
stuff here for us all right so that's
the package.json
then inside of the disk there's where
our application is going to go when it
builds
then we have the src folder and that's
the folder that we're going to be
working in
so we have some different stuff here
inside of the src folder we have an
image folder with
all the bricks the ball and also the
paddle
should be here yeah and then i have an
index.d.ts file and this is because i
want to
be able to import these images so i have
to declare this
p and the images and specify type for
them otherwise we can't import them
as a module and it's very convenient to
import them as a module
then we have the index.html file so this
is the index.html file that parcel will
use when we build
our application and you can see here
that i created a canvas
i also have a background that background
is positioned
below the canvas so the canvas is
transparent and this image is shown
below that camera so that's why we can
see that star background
then i have a div with the display and
the start button and some info
if it's game over or what's happening
and then
the script tag that will import a script
and i created some basic styles for us
so this is in no way
a finished game so to say the main
purpose with this tutorial is to get
some solid
typescript practice so there's a lot of
stuff you can do with this game
if you want to expand it and add in
functionality and also
restyle it and make it even more
beautiful
right then we have the index.ts file and
this is the main file
you could also create a class for it if
you want and call it something like
game class or something i don't know i'm
going to have the main stuff for the
game inside over here and we're going to
create classes for the bricks
for the paddle and for the ball and also
class for the view
so we're going to add that stuff in here
then i have a setup.ts file
and here you can see that i'm importing
my images
and that's why i needed that little type
declaration here so that i can import
the images like this
then i grab the canvas and i'm going to
set up some stuff for us here
we're going to set the stage padding
stage row columns
brick padding brick width and you can
see that i calculate the brick width and
height
depending on the size of the canvas so
that's what i'm doing here
and we can set the pedal width height
start x speed yeah
a lot of stuff that you can just change
here and it will hopefully work
when you change these values then i have
a lookup object
for my brick images so i import them
here and then i place them in this
lookup object with different keys here
one to five and that means that i can
create my level here so if for example i
have
the number two here it will grab the
green brick
and this is from top to bottom so we
don't have to care about the blank space
below the bricks so we start from top
and then we
draw our bricks we're going to have five
of them and i also assign
different kind of energy levels to these
bricks
so for example the purple brick you're
gonna have to hit them three times
before it disappear
and we're going to see this in action
later in the course
so that's the setup then i set up some
basic types that's the share type for
the vector the
x and y position maybe overkill to have
a
separate file when there's only this
that is shared so yeah
but it's always good to have a file
where you can put your shared types and
you can import them because you can see
that i'm exported here
so you can import this type to any file
where you want to use it
all right so that's the starter files
let's continue on and create the canvas
view
make sure that you started up your dev
environment and you have everything in
place you are using the starter files
and you have run npm install
and to run the dev environment you type
in mpm start and you will be good to go
we're going to start creating a class
that we're going to call view
so inside the src folder create the new
folder that we call
view like this
and inside of that one we create a new
file
that we call canvas view capital c
capital v dot ts
and it's going to work like this that
are going to create a view class
for us to use because now we're going to
draw on the canvas so i'm going to
create a specific class
that will be able to draw on the canvas
and this is because
let's say that you don't have a canvas
and you want to draw your game
in another way then you can create a
specific class and as long as it has the
same interface
the same methods to call you can always
swap this class out
so that's why it's good to keep it in
modules like this and i will also say
that typescript and javascript is not
really
a true object-oriented language so
that's why i'm not going to go
all in on classes i'm going to use
classes for most of the part
but for example as i told you before the
index.ts is not going to be a class i'm
going to create the code directly inside
of that file and don't create the game
class
so it's going to be a combination of
classes and regular javascript files
in this one all right so we're going to
create our class and actually this view
class
is also going to need the brick paddle
and ball class so we're going to
scaffold these ones out
and we're going to come back to those
classes and and finish them later
so inside src folder create a new folder
that we call
sprites i call them sprites
create a new file bool.ts
and another file that's called paddle
dot ts and the third file that's called
brick dot ts and inside of these
classes we can just scaffold them out
and for all of these classes we're going
to need that vector
in this types.ts file that i showed you
so go back to the ball.ts we import
i think i'm going to bump up the font
size a little bit so we import
curly brackets or vector capital v
from dot dot forward slash
types so that's the types for the vector
the
x and y then we have to export this
class as we're going to use it in
another file
export class ball
capital b like this
and that's enough for now that's our
scaffolding of the class for now we're
going to come back to this later
grab this code copy it and also save the
file
go inside the brick dot ts and we paste
it in in the brick
class and we rename it to brick save it
then we go inside the paddle do the same
thing paste it and change it
to paddle and save it and now we can use
these and import them in our canvas view
so go back to the canvas view class
i'm going to mark this with types so
import
brick from dot dot forward slash
sprites forward slash brick
like this and then we have two more
import paddle
from dot dot forward slash sprites
forward slash
paddle and the last one
we're gonna import ball from
note.forward slash sprites
ball and you can see here that this is
actually the classes that we import here
but when we're in typescript when we
create a class we can also use these
ones
as a type so typescript will create a
type for us when we create a class
automatically
so we can both use them as a class and
as a type and in this case we're going
to use them as a type
all right then we create our canvasview
class so export class
canvas view capital c capital view
like this and this class is going to
have some methods and also some
properties
so i want to create these properties as
private properties that's something we
have in typescript
so only this class can access these
properties so i like to create the
properties as private
if it's possible if we don't want to use
them outside of this class
and it's always a good idea to isolate
everything that you can inside a class
if we don't need to use it outside of
the class
so we're going to specify some types
first for these private properties it's
going to be five of them
and when you specify type in a class
with typescript
you do it up here outside of the
constructor
so private canvas
and that one is going to be an html
canvas element yeah and now it will
complain because we haven't actually
created this one
so that's why we're going to fix that in
a second we're just typing these ones
now
and we type another one private context
this one is going to be a canvas
rendering
context 2d or it can also be null so we
have a pipe and null
so that's the type for the context then
we're going to have a score display
private score display
it's going to be an html object element
that is going to be the div where we
render out the score
and we have a pipe it can also be null
then we have a private
start that's going to be the start
button that's also going to be an html
object element and a pipe and null
and we have a private that's called info
that's going to display some information
for the player
and that's also going to be an html
object
element or null
like this so that's our types then we
can create a constructor
that we need for a class we're going to
take in one parameter for this one
and that's the canvas name so this one
is going to be dynamic
and we can specify exactly what canvas
we want to use
so that's going to be the name for
example you can see here in the
index.html i
have a name on this that's called play
field that's the id
so that's going to be the one that we
send in here to make it a little bit
dynamic
we have curly brackets and we can create
the stuff inside of our constructor for
the class
so we're defining this canvas up here as
a private property
and we access this on this dot canvas
like this and you can see that now it
won't complain because we're creating it
in the constructor now
and from the document dot
query selector
we're going to grab the div with the
canvas name
and that's of course this one here it's
going to be string and we also want to
specify it as
an html canvas element like this so
we're telling typescript that this one
that we grabbed here
from this canvas is going to be a ht an
html canvas element and you can see if
we hover
over this you can see that the canvas
view
dot canvas is going to be of the type
html canvas element
so when you hover over stuff you can see
the type of stuff here and that's what i
did here to
to find this type when i created the
canvas and i
created these variables i can hover over
it and that this type for the specific
canvas is called html canvas element
right then we're going to create the
context this context
equal and from this dot canvas
we're going to get context and we want
to grab the 2d
context like this and you can see if we
hover
that this canvasview.context is going to
be of the type canvas rendering context
2d
or null
then we have this dot score
display it's gonna equal to document
query selector
and we're gonna grab a div that's called
a hash symbol
score
and if we look again in the index.html
you can see that i have this
div here so that's what we're grabbing
and put in these variables in this class
we have this start that's going to be
the start button that we grab from
document query selected the
document query selector
and it's called we have the hash symbol
and it's called start and the last one
is going to be this dot info equal
document
dot query selector we have a hash symbol
again
and it's called info so that's all of
the properties we need for this class
and we initialize them in the
constructor here and with this parameter
we can send in whatever div we want to
grab
for the canvas then we're going to have
some
methods in this class so first we want a
method to clear
the canvas and we're going to call it
clear
this one is not going to return anything
so we specify it as colon
void because we're returning void we
return nothing
so that's how you specify it in
typescript when you have a function that
won't return anything
you specify the return type as void and
we have the context this is the one that
we're going to work with
with the canvas we have created this
context from the canvas
so this dot context and also this can be
null and that's no good because this
will complain and we can tell type
script
with a question mark like this so this
is called
optional shading if it can't find this
one it will return undefined for us
so that's very handy to have that
question marked
and you can put it anywhere in the chain
gonna grab your properties
and it will return undefined if it can't
find it on the context we have a method
that's called clear rect
oh did you see that i typed in clear
react that's because i work with react
so i have it in my fingers but it should
be clear wrecked
like this and we specify it at the point
zero
and zero that's the top left and then we
have this
canvas dot width we grab the width of
the canvas
and we have this dot canvas dot height
and this is going to clear the complete
canvas
and that's what we want to do on every
frame that we draw we're first going to
clear everything and then we're going to
draw on new stuff
and you can see if i remove this
question mark here it will complain and
tell us that this cam
object is possible null and that's no
good so if we use this optional chaining
question mark
it will return undefined if we can't
find it so it's very handy
okay so that's our clear method then
we're going to have a method to init our
start button
and we call it init start button and to
this method we can provide a function
that will trigger when we click the
button so we're going to call this
parameter start function
and our start function also need to get
the view
so we have a parameter view and that for
sure we know is going to be a canvas
view and the canvas view is of course
this one that we're creating here so we
use this as a type here
for this one and it's going to return
void so we have an arrow function here
that we say is going to return void
and also this init start button is going
to return void
all right so what's going on here okay
we have this in
start button method this method is going
to take in another function
that we want to attach to our start
button so we can provide
any function we want to our start button
and that function for the start button
is going to need the views so we're
going to send in the view and this is
the actual view that we're working on
and also that function is going to
return void and
this method that's called in its start
button is also going to return void
so this dot start this can also be
null so we have our optional chaining or
question mark
we're gonna add an event listener to
this one
we're gonna listen for the click event
and then we have our function we create
an inline function because we
want to send along this parameter to our
start function
and we give it this this is going to be
this class that we're working on in this
case so it's going to be the canvas view
and we're telling it here that this
parameter needs to be of the type canvas
view
and we're telling it here that this
needs to be of the type canvas view so
that's why we can provide the canvas
view
to the start function so that's the
initialization of our start button
then we need something to draw a score
so we have a method called draw score
it's going to take in the score and this
is going to be a number
it's it also going to return void
like this so if this dot score display
because this can also be null
so in this case we check with an if
statement if this dot score display
if we have a score display we're going
to set this dot score display
dot inner html
to the score score and we
convert it to a string to string
like this so that's how we draw the
score to our div
that we grab up here score display
then we want to draw draw some
information about game over
and game start and stuff like that so we
have another method that's called
draw info we have the text it's going to
be a string
so that's the text that goes inside of
that information div
it also going to return nothing so we
specify the return type to void
if this dot info if we have this info
element
this dot info dot inner html
is going to equal to the text and this
one is already going to be a string so
we don't have to convert it to a string
so that's the info then we need
something to draw our sprites and the
sprites is going to be the bricks ball
or paddle
and we can use this method to draw all
of them
so draw sprite
then we have the brick and this can be
of the type
brick we have a pipe because we want
another type this is how we can specify
multiple types and it can be a paddle
and it can also be a ball and it's going
to return nothing so we specify the
return type to void
and the first thing we're going to do is
to check if we have a brick if
exclamation mark brick if we don't have
a brick we're going to return earlier so
we
return we do nothing but if we have a
brick
we're going to draw something on the
contact so this dot context
we have a question mark this optional
shaning thing again
and we call draw image because these are
images that we want to draw on our
canvas
and we have a method for that on our
canvas object
so draw image and first we specify the
image
so brick dot image so these are
properties that we're going to create in
the brick class later we're going to
attach an image that's going to be a
string
so we're going to attach the image and
we're also going to attach a position
with an heart
so we specify the image and then we have
the brick dot pos
dot x and we have the brick dot pos dot
y and we have the brick dot width
and we have the brick dot height
like this and of course this one's
doesn't exist yet so that's why it will
complain here
so we will get an error if we try to if
we try to save this and run this
no hope i think it will give no it
actually won't give us an error because
we're not using this class yet
these ones are going to be fixed when we
create the brick that we're going to
send into this function
so all of these ones bridge parallel and
ball need to have these properties
otherwise this won't work and you may
also wonder ball that one is round yeah
it is
but we're actually going to have this as
a brick also because it's an image with
a transparent background
so if we look in the images for the ball
you can see here that
it has this transparent background so
it's a round image
inside of this square so that's why i'm
going to use it as a brick also
all right so that's draw sprite and the
last method we're going to have is draw
bricks
and this one is going to get an array
with all the bricks so we have the brick
and we specify it as an array so this is
how you type an array
you have the type and then you create
these square brackets
just to the right of the type and this
will tell typescript that this is going
to be an array where each element is
going to be a brick
and it's going to return nothing so we
specify the return type to void
so this method is going to receive an
array with all the bricks that we want
to draw so the bricks
dot for each for each of these bricks
we're going to loop through them
we have a brick an inline arrow function
and we call this method here draw sprite
so this
dot draw sprite
and we give it a brick so this is how we
can um
and of course this one needs to have an
s so this is how it's going to work we
send in all the bricks we loop through
them and for each brick we're going to
draw this sprite
on the canvas and this is
everything for our canvas view it may
seem a little bit
tricky right now because we haven't seen
it in action yet
so that's what we're going to do later i
think it will get more clear
when we actually use this class to draw
something on the canvas so
next we're going to scaffold out some
stuff in the index file and then we're
going to continue on to create our
bricks
and we can draw the bricks on the canvas
so we have our canvas view our little
class that
makes it possible for us to draw on the
canvas that we have in the index.html
this canvas here so that's great
we have some small little errors here
now but that one is going to be fixed
when we create these properties on the
classes here
but first we're going to scaffold out
some stuff in the index.ts file
so move inside of that file so we remove
this here
and we're going to import some stuff
first import the canvas view
from dot forward slash view
canvas view we need all the sprites
so import ball from dot forward slash
sprites
ball and we import
the brick from dot forward slash sprites
brick and we
import the paddle from
not forward slash sprites you guessed it
paddle then we're going to need some
images
so i mark it with images so i'm going to
import
paddle underscore image
from dot forward slash images
paddle dot png
so i have kept the letters and
underscore on this one so that is
obviously going to be the image for the
paddle
and then we import ball underscore image
you can name them to whatever you want
they don't need to be named like this
and this is what's so sweet and that's
why i created this type declaration for
the images
so that i can import them like an es6
module like this
we have four dot forward slash images
forward slash
ball dot png
uh from like this
so that's the images then we're going to
import some stuff
from our setup we have a lot of stuff
here that we need to use
inside of the index file so that's what
i'm going to import next
and i'm going to mark it with the level
and colors so import
we have the pedal underscore speed
we have the pedal underscore
with we have the paddle
underscore height
the paddle underscore start x
that's where we want the paddle to start
on our play field
then we have the ball underscore speed
the ball underscore
size the ball underscore start
x and the ball underscores dot y
we're going to import them from
not forward slash setup
so that's the values from the setup file
we're also going to have a few
lets here so let gameover equal
false we set it to false as a default
value
and let's score and it's going to have 0
as a default
value then i'm just going to scaffold
out some functions here
function set game over
and this one is going to take in a view
so view and we use the canvas
view as a type for this one
and inside of this function we have we
call the view dot
draw info that's the one that we created
here
we have a method that's called draw info
so you can see here i'm going to send in
a string and this function is going to
draw something in this div
back to the index draw info
game over maybe an exclamation mark to
be extra clear that it's game over and
then we set the game over
to false because later we're going to
set this one to true and we're going to
trigger this function later
and then when we have drawn this we're
going to set it back to false so that we
can start the game again
and then we have a function that's
called set
win it's also going to take in the view
and the canvas view and we have the view
draw info
game one
and we set the game over to false on
this one also
and as you can see here this is actually
exactly the same function
we're just changing this text here so we
could have one function instead
where we send in the string that we want
to draw but sometimes it's
good to separate out the logic if we for
example want to do something else when
we win the game
or when we lose the game it can be good
to have them in separate functions
so that's why i didn't do it in one
function then we're gonna have a
function that's called
game loop and this one is going to have
some parameters this is going to be the
main
game loop that we have and it needs the
view it's going to be on the type canvas
view
it's going to need the bricks and this
is going to be
an array with our bricks we have a
paddle
of the type paddle we have a ball of the
type
ball and then later we're also going to
add in some collisions this one
we create curly brackets and actually i
just realized
that i created a private up here that's
called canvas
this shouldn't actually be private
because we need to access the canvas
from this game loop
so up here where we declare the type
remove private from canvas
otherwise we won't be able to call this
one from the game loop
very important inside of canvas view
remove private
on this one then we can go back to the
index dot ts
so that's our function that's called
game loop then we have a function that's
called start
game it's going to take in the view
and it's going to be of the type canvas
view
so just scaffolding in the mouth now i'm
leaving them empty
and down below here we can start our
view so create
a new view const view
we have created this class but it won't
work now
as we have these little arrows inside of
it new canvas
view and we're going to grab the div
that's called
playfield in this case i haven't
stripped out this
hash symbol so it's very important to
include this hash symbol
and if we go back inside of the canvas
view you can see that
it's the one that we grab here we send
it in here to the class
and then we use this one here so back to
the index
we create a new view and then from the
view we're going to run
the init start button
and we're going to give it the start
game function
so we first create a view and then we
run this method on the view class to
initialize the start button and the
start button will get the click handler
that will call this start game function
when we click on it
and now it probably won't work i'm
actually amazed
that it works still because we have
these errors
but yeah hey it has something to do with
the default settings
the default setup that it won't
break the application but these ones
won't work now all right so that's the
scaffolding of the
index and we're going to continue on and
create our brick class
all right let's create our brick class
so inside the sprites we have the
brick.tiers
file we're already importing the vector
and we are setting up our class here
for this one we're going to need a
private property
private brick image
and this one is going to be an html
image element
and we're going to create a new image
like this so if i remove this one here
this type
so if we hover over this one you can see
that this one is going to be of the type
html image element so you actually don't
have to specify it if you don't want to
do that because it will interpret it
itself so we can leave that out
but sometimes it's good to be extra
specific
so if we copy this type here and that's
what i meant before also if you hover
over stuff you can
usually see the type that you want and
you can specify it
like this to be extra clear but you
don't have to do it in this case because
when we create this image it will
understand that this one is of the type
html image element
but now at least it's easy to see just
by looking at it
that it's going to be of this type so
this is the only private property that
we need to specify here i'm going to
show you a little trick
now constructor
we can actually specify the type inside
of the constructor
when we have parameters to the
constructor that we don't need to create
something or modify something like this
if we're sending something here where
we're just going to use that value
we can specify the type inside of here
so private
brick with is going to be a number
and private brick height
is going to be a number private position
it's going to be vector
and private brick
energy is going to be a number
and then we're also going to send in the
image string that's the path to the
image
so it's going to be able to type string
all right so that's the constructor
and then we have the curly brackets and
we're inside the constructor
so we have created these short cuts here
of creating the types
instead of setting them up here
private brick with
it's going to be a type number we don't
have to do that when we're going to use
these values
values and assign them here we can just
set them up like this
and they're going to have the same name
so that's what i'm going to show you
here
now for example the brick with
so we create this property brick with
equal brick with so if we have the same
name here
this one will create this private
property and we can assign the value
here
directly to that this brick
height equal brick height
this dot position
is going to equal position
this dot brick energy
is going to equal brick energy
and then the last one that's the one up
here that we had to create here because
we're creating a new image here so we
can't really use this parameter as it is
so we assign this parameter to this dot
brick image dot src
so we create this one up here and then
we set the src
to the path of the image all right so we
have all these
private properties and how do we access
them
from outside we can do that with
something that's called
getters and setters so i'm going to
create some getters
for these private properties and we use
the keyword get
with it's going to be of the type
number so when we get the property
that's called
with it's going to return this dot brick
with for us and this means that we could
do some stuff here if we for example if
we want to grab the width from this one
we can do some stuff before we actually
grab this private value here so that's
why it's good to have getters
we can do whatever we want inside of
here before we actually return the value
and you
and that's the same with the setter you
can do some stuff and then set the value
instead of accessing this value directly
from outside of the class
so we call this getter and we can
control exactly
what we will get back when we call this
getter
right we're going to do that for the
other properties also get
height it's going to be the type
number return this dot
brick height
get position get push
it's going to be at the type vector in
this case
return this dot position
get image
this one is going to be of the html
image element
type
return this dot brick
image right
we have a few more no we only have one
more
get energy it's gonna be the type number
return this dot brick energy
so that's our getters and you can see
here that's really sweet because we can
keep all this private to the class
and we can only access these properties
with these getters
otherwise another class or another
document another file or another
function
won't be able to get these values so we
can control it exactly how we want to
receive these values
and we can also set setter
when we want to set the entity set
energy
it's going to take in a number
and it's going to be of the type number
so you can imagine here we can do some
stuff also before we set the value if we
want to do that but in our case we're
only going to
pass this on this dot brick energy is
going to equal to the number
maybe this one can be called energy
instead
to make it a little bit more readable
and concise so this
is our class this is our brick class
so it's essentially only properties here
that we set with a width height and
position the energy
and also the image for the brick we
don't have any methods on this class
because they won't do anything the
bricks they are only just there on the
canvas they can't do
anything they only have the energy that
we're going to keep track of
on when to remove that brick so save
this file
and next we're going to create a little
helper function that is going to create
an
array with all our bricks that we have
here in the setup and this play field
where the bricks are
so we have different bricks here and
we're going to create a function
that will create a new array for us
strip out all this blank space
and create an array with all these
bricks for us
we have created our brick class and we
have to create an
array with all the bricks that we can
use for our games because we're going to
have more than one brick
and inside the canvas view we can
actually remove this for now
the paddle and the ball and we can add
them in later
for the drawsprite method and then these
arrows will just
disappear so do that and save the file
and we add them in later when we create
the ball and the paddle
and now we're going to add a new file
here in the src folder
create a new file at the root of the src
that we call helpers.ts
we're going to import the brick
from dot forward slash sprites brick
like this and then we need some values
from
the setup so import we need the brick
images
we also need the level we need a stage
underscore calls we need the stage
underscore padding whoops
padding we need the brick underscore
with
we need a brick underscore height
we need a brick underscore padding
and the brick underscore energy
and we grab them from dot forward slash
setup and of course
these are the ones that we have here
that we can import wherever we want to
use them
so back to the helpers.ts and now we're
going to create this little
function that will create an array with
all the bricks for us to use for the
game
so we're going to export this function
we call it create bricks we don't have
any parameters to this one
it's going to return an array of bricks
so brick
and square brackets and that will tell
typescript that it will return an array
where each element is going to be a
brick and now we can see that it
completes because we're not returning
anything now so
this one is obviously going to be fixed
when we return something
so if we look in the setup we have this
array here the level array where i
specify all of the brick types
and now we're going to loop through this
array and create another array
with all the positions and stuff for the
bricks
so inside this function create bricks in
the helpers file
i'm going to return from the level
i'm going to reduce because we're not
going to
return an array of the same length we're
going to strip out the zeros for example
where we're not going to draw anything
so that's why i use reduce if we for
example map through them
you have to return an array of the same
length
so we're going to have the accumulator
we're going to have a cell
and we're going to have the iterator and
the cell
is going to be each element in the array
i don't know if it's correct to call it
cell actually we could call it
element instead maybe like this
do as you want and then i had curly
brackets for this error function so
inside of here first i'm going to create
a const
that i call row and i got a math.floor
i have the i the current number that
we're on i'm going to add in one because
it starts at zero
then i divide it with the stage
underscore calls and this is going to
give us the current row that this
specific
brick is going to be on and then i'm
going to have a const for a column
and i have the i and i use the modulo
on the stage underscore calls and that
is going to give us the correct column
for that specific brick
and then we're going to calculate the x
and y value for the brick that we're
currently on
const x equal
i'm going to take into consideration the
stage
underscore padding that we can define
also that's the padding if we look
we're going to have some padding here on
the edges
of the stage so that's what we can
specify ourself how much this padding is
going to be
we want some space between the walls and
the bricks so that's why i have this
padding
then i'm going to add the column
times and i have the brick underscore
with
plus i also have a padding on the brick
we want some space
between the bricks so brick underscore
padding
so that's the x value and then we have
the y value
yet again i consider the stage padding
and in this case i'm going to add the
row
times i have the brick underscore height
plus the brick underscore padding
like this and this is going to give us
the correct x and y values
hopefully and then i check if cell
equals zero
we're going to return the accumulator we
don't do anything so that's how we strip
out all the zeros
if we just return the accumulator we're
not creating a new element so that is
why it's stripped out
but if the cell isn't and yet we rename
this one actually to
element so it's going to be element
instead of cell
and then on each iteration we're going
to return
an array i spread out the accumulator
that will keep the old values
and then i add in a new element to this
array and i create a new brick
for that one
and the brick that we created up here in
the sprites
you can see that it takes in some
parameters here so we have to specify
some arguments where the brick with the
height position
energy and the image so that's what
we're going to specify here
so we have the brick width first
then we have the brick height
and then we're going to specify the x
and y coordinates and that's a vector
object
so i create an object here i give it x
and y
it's important to have coma here also
between all of these ones
then we have the brick underscore energy
not height
energy and we have to grab this specific
energy for this brick
and from the brick energy if we look in
the setup
this one is an object and we know the
brick number
so if we're on brick three it's going to
grab these values so this is
what's called a lookup object where we
can specify the property and it will
grab the value
if we give it the element we know which
number that is so we grab that specific
energy for
for the element and we can do the same
on the brick underscore images
we give it element element like this
and then as this is a reduce we need to
specify a start value for this one
and i'm going to specify it down below
here just before the end parenthesis
it's going to be an array but it won't
be satisfied with that
actually because we have to specify it
as
a brick array like this
and then it will be satisfied
when we specify it like this we tell the
reduce function that the
start array is going to be interpreted
as an array with bricks
and this brick images is also a lookup
object
inside of this setup
so if we have the value 3 for example
from this array here
we know that this is the yellow brick
image and it works the same here on the
brick energy
so go back to the helpers and i'm just
going to recap what i did here
so in this create bricks function i'm
going to reduce that level that we have
i'm going to loop through
every item with the reduce method
i create a row and a column for the
brick that we're currently on
and then i calculate the x and the y
position depending on the row and the
column
so we get an x and y value where we're
going to position this
brick on the canvas if this element is
zero
if we look here we have all these zeros
here we don't need to do anything with
these
so we're going to strip them out so if
it's zero we return the accumulator
and don't put a new element in this
array otherwise we create the brick
so i spread out the old accumulator to
keep the old values and then i add in
the new value
i create a new brick i give it the width
height and the x and y position
and the energy and the images so this
array is going to be an array with
bricks
hopefully and now if we go back to the
index
dot ts file we can hopefully draw some
bricks on the canvas
and here below this where we import the
setup
i'm going to mark this with helpers and
i'm not going to import
create bricks from
dot forward slash helpers so we import
this function
so that we can use it in our code
and down below here we're already
initiating the game we are setting up
the start button
and it's going to run the start game
function
and that's this one here and in this
start
game function we're first gonna reset
the displays when we start the game
we set the score to zero
view dot draw info
we're going to set it to an empty string
to clear that div
and view dot raw score
we're going to give it a zero we set the
score to zero
not only in the variable in the left
here but we also want to show the user
a score of zero so that's why we reset
it like this
first in the variable the left and then
in the view itself
then we're going to create all bricks
with this function that we created now
so i create a new const
bricks equal create bricks
and this is hopefully going to return
all the bricks for us so if we look on
the return type here you can see that
the return type is
an array of bricks right
we're going to call our game loop
and we give it the view and the bricks
and this won't work now because we
specify this here
that it should have all of these
parameters view bricks paddle and ball
we don't have the paddle and ball so i'm
going to comment these ones out
and now you can see that it won't
complain because now we give it the view
and we give it the bricks and inside
here
of course we're going to add this in
later when we create the paddle and the
ball so the first
thing we do in our game loop is to
actually clear the canvas so view dot
clear we have already
already created this method when we
created the canvas view
and then we call the view dot draw
bricks
and we give it to bricks so view draw
bricks
and then we're going to use request
animation frame so instead of setting an
interval i'm using request animation
frame to make sure that we
don't do any renders that's unnecessary
a request animation frame requires
a function and we're going to call our
game loop again
and give it the view and the bricks
so this will keep the loop forever and
forever until we break it
save reload
press play and you can see that we have
this one here and now it will keep on
looping looping
but if we go to sources and click pause
that will pause the game loop
we can also console.log
like this to see it in action so i
reload it
go to the console click start and you
can see the drawers drawers drawers
cross clothes
and if we don't want it to be like this
now we can go to sources here in chrome
and press pause and that will break it
alright so that's our bricks let's add
in the paddle next
so we have our bricks move back inside
of the code
and inside the paddle.ts file inside of
the sprites folder
we're already importing the vector and
we're exporting a class that's called
paddle
this one is going to have a private
paddle image
property and it's going to be of the
type html
image element and we create a new image
just as before we have a private move
left it's going to be a boolean
and we have a private move right it's
also going to be a boolean
we have a constructor and we have a few
more that i'm setting here
the shortcut that i showed you before
private
speed is going to be a type number
we have a private paddle width it's
going to be
of type number private pedal height
it's going to be a type number and
private
position it's going to be of type vector
and the image is going to be a string
right we have curly brackets and we can
create our constructor
so we're going to set this.speed it's
going to be the speed
this dot paddle width
is going to be the paddle with
this dot paddle height
it's going to be the paddle height
this dot position is going to be the
position
this dot move left it's going to be set
to false
as initial value and this dot move right
is also going to be set to false
and this dot paddle image
dot src is going to be the image string
that we send in
with the path to the image all right
that's all the properties that we need
for this one we're going to do one more
thing inside of this constructor and
that is to set up the event listeners on
the keyboard
event listeners like this
so on the document we add an event
listener
that's called key down
and we're going to call a method handle
key down
for this one we haven't created this one
yet but we're going to do that in a
second
and document add event listener
key up and we have a method that we're
going to create that is called this dot
handle key up
like this we're going to use the arrow
functions and when we press
either the right or the left arrow
function we're going to trigger the key
down
and the key up when we release it then
just as before we want to
access these private values so we need
to have some getters for these ones
get with it's going to be
a number return this dot
pedal width
get height it's also going to be a type
number
return this dot
paddle height
could also copy them if we want and
paste them in but i like to repeat stuff
when i teach
code so get pause
it's going to be a vector return
this dot position
we have the image get image it's going
to be an html image element
return this dot paddle image
we're also going to need to retrieve the
move left and move right boolean so get
is
moving left it's going to be a boolean
return this dot move
left and we do the same with the move
right
get is moving right
boolean
return this dot move right
so that's our get us then we're going to
create our methods we're going to have
three of them
we're going to have a method that's
called move paddle
we don't have any parameters this one
and it's going to return nothing so we
set it
to void so this method is going to be
used when we want to move our pedal
so if this dot move left
we're going to set this dot pos dot x so
if we move to the left
we're going to subtract something from
this value so minus equal sign
this dot speed so we subtract the speed
if we're moving left
if this dot move right
this dot pos dot x is going to be
plus equal sign this dot speed
so we have these booleans and we can
check against them to see in which
direction we're moving so if we're
moving left we're going to subtract the
speed that we set for this
paddle from the x value and if we're
moving right we're going to add the
speed value
so that's how we move left and right
then we need
two more methods we need the handle key
up
and for these ones i create arrow
functions because these ones are going
to be called here
from these ones so i have error
functions so i won't
assign anything to this so we can use
this to grab these booleans this move
left and this move
right if we don't have an error function
we have to bind
this value but we can use arrow
functions to make it a little bit
simpler for us
so this one is going to take in the
event it's going to be a keyboard
event and it returns nothing so we set
it to void
we have an arrow function curly brackets
and inside here
if e dot code equals
arrow left capital a and capital l
or we can also check against e dot key
if that one is equal
arrow left
we're going to set this dot move left
equal to false because this is the
handle key up
so we're going to set the value to false
because we're not pressing any key
we're not moving so this is why i had
the arrow function
otherwise i won't be able to access this
this ec as i do now
then we have the ife.code equal
arrow write or
double pipe e dot key equal
arrow right
this dot move right is going to be set
to false
some order formatting and it will put it
on its own row
nice so then we have the handle key down
handle key down equal
we have the event we have a keyboard
event again we return nothing
so we set it to void we have an arrow
function curly brackets and if e dot
code
equal arrow left
double pipe we check against the e dot
key
equal arrow left
this dot move left is going to be set to
true because this is the handle key down
so then we're moving if e dot code
equal arrow right
double pipe e dot key equal
arrow right this dot move right
it's going to be set to true
and you could of course also combine
these ones into one function
if you want to do that but i like to be
specific it's easier to see this way
which will handle the key up and which
one which will handle the key down
and this is all there is to it to this
paddle class so we have this move paddle
it's going to check against these
booleans
move left and move right that we set in
the handle key up handle key down when
we press the keys so if these ones
are set to true we're going to move the
paddle and we can move
back to the index.ts file
we're already importing the paddle up
here
so we can create a new paddle and we're
going to do that in the start
game function create
a parallel const paddle
equal new paddle we're going to give it
all these values that we want when we
initialize the parallel
so we have the paddle underscore speed
that we imported from the setup and we
have the paddle underscore width that we
also imported
we have the paddle underscore height
we're going to give it some coordinates
to start with and that is an object
so we set the x to paddle
underscore start x
and this panel is always going to be at
the bottom of the screen
so we can set the y value to view dot
canvas
dot height minus
paddle underscore height and then i just
have a value here because i want some
padding here also
from the bottom so i set -5
on this one
yeah and we also want to give it
some more values here we want to give it
the paddle
underscore image
and this is also why i changed this one
in the view
this one that was a private first it
shouldn't be
private because then we can't access it
like i do here now
the view.canvas.height so that's why
so we have the paddle and we're going to
send in the pedal to the game loop
so we add paddle this will complain now
because we also have to
uncomment this one here
we need to have a coma like this so we
have the paddle
also we need to add it here because
we're calling this
game loop all the time here and we also
want to draw our paddle
and we're going to set some constraints
on this pedal we can do that
in the pedal class itself also but i
want it to be more dynamic so that's why
i'm going to do that
check here so i mark it with move paddle
and check so it won't
exit the play field so that's what i'm
going to check here
we don't want to be able to move outside
of the borders so if
i'm gonna have parentheses i'm gonna
check the paddle dot
is moving left we first check if we're
moving
double ampersands then we check the
paddle dot
pos dot x if that one is greater than
zero we don't want to be able to move
outside of the border to the left so we
know that when the paddle
has an x position of zero we're as far
as left as we want to go
then we also want to check some other
stuff so we have double pipes
a new pair of parentheses i checked the
pedal is
moving right double ampersands
if the paddle paddle.pos dot x is
less than the view
canvas.width you can see that i grabbed
that canvas from the view here also
that's also related to that one where we
remove the private one
otherwise we can't access it here like i
do so we check if the paddle position
is less than the canvas width but that's
not enough we also have to subtract
the paddle dot width
we check the left border and the right
border
we have curly brackets and then we're
going to call the paddle dot
move paddle that's the method that we
created in the paddle
so of course we also have to draw this
panel on the
canvas so here just below the view dot
draw bricks
view dot draw
sprite and we send in the panel
and now you can see any complaints
because we remove this from the canvas
view we're only telling it
that it can draw a brick so we're going
to add this one in now
we have a pipe and we specify it as a
paddle
so this is what's so great about
typescript it's telling you when you're
doing something wrong
and you can correct it so now we can
also send in a paddle to this draw
sprite
save the index go back to our game click
start
and now we have our pedal and we can
move you can see that it stops
at the edges so it seems to be working
and i'm so happy with it but we can't
really play something we need to have a
ball also so that's what we're going to
do next we're going to create the ball
we have our paddle and our bricks so
we're going to create a ball
so that we actually can play this game
because now
it's of no use for us so
i'm gonna break this one and i'm gonna
go back to my code
editor and inside the ball.ts file in
the sprites folder
we have our ball class we're gonna have
a private property that's called speed
it's gonna be of the type vector and we
have a private
ball image it's gonna be an html image
element
equal new image just as before
we have a constructor and it's going to
take in the speed
as a parameter it's going to be the type
number
and we're going to have the image it's
going to be the type string and then we
have
maybe we can have them at the top we
have a private
ball size
number and a private position
that's going to be of the vector type
curly brackets and inside of the
constructor we're going to set this dot
ball size
it's going to be the ball size and this
dot position
is going to be the position this dot
speed
is going to be an object where we set
the x value to the speed
and we set the y value to minus speed
and that's because we want the ball
initially to go up so this is what we're
doing here when we subtract
from the y value the ball will go up up
up up up instead of down
so that's what we're setting it to
initially then we have this
dot ball image dot src is going to equal
to the image
that we sent in so that's the
constructor
then we have some getters for this one
with it's going to be a number
return this dot ball size
and get height also going to be a number
and this one is also going to return the
ball size because
it has the same width and height this
dot ball size
and that's because i'm creating this
like a square as i said before
so it's not really a circle that we draw
on the canvas it's a square image
so get pause it's going to be vector
return this dot position
i'm doing this a little bit faster now
as we have done this before so that's
why
get image it's going to be an html
image element and return
this dot ball image
so that's the getters for this class
then we have some methods
you can actually mark it with methods
we're going to create a method that's
called change y direction
it's going to return nothing so we set
it to void
and this one is going to change this dot
speed
dot by to minus this dot speed
dot y and that will change the direction
on the ball
and then we have another method change x
direction
and return type is going to be void
this dot speed dot x
is going to equal minus this dot speed
dot x so it's nice to have it in its own
small little methods like this that we
can call when we want to change the
direction
and then we're going to have a method
that's called move ball
we return we set the return type to void
and this dot pos dot x is going to equal
this dot plus dot x plus
this dot p dot x or we can do it like
this instead plus equal sign
like this so it's a little bit shorter
this dot plus dot y
plus equal this dot speed dot y
like this nice and clean so this is
everything we need for the board class
let's move back inside of the index.ts
file we're already importing the ball up
here
so we have to create a ball first we can
do that before the paddle here i think
create
a ball
const ball equal new ball
and we give it the ball underscore speed
we give it the ball underscore size
and we have the vector
the position is going to be an x it's
going to be the ball
underscore start x and the y
is going to be ball underscore start
y and then we have the ball underscore
image okay the ball size did i do a
mistake
i'm gonna go back to the ball class yeah
and of course
that is because i rearranged them here
so we should of course have the speed
first
then we should have the ball size the
position and the image so yeah
i couldn't rearrange them as i did there
then i had to rearrange them
also in the index so move this speed up
here
and have the two private ones in the
middle save the file
go back to the index we have the ball
then we have the game loop we're gonna
send in the ball also
so we add in the ball and we have to
change it up here
uncomment this one and add a coma so
that's our
ball and we have to add it in here also
like this now we have to draw the ball
so up here somewhere below the pedal
from the view we call the draw sprite
and we send in the ball and now it will
complain again
because we don't have this type so we go
back to the canvas type
and we add in the ball type to the draw
sprite
method save it go back to the index.ts
so we're drawing the ball here
and now we have to move the ball also
move
ball ball dot move ball we call
that method that we created i think that
should be it
go back to our game reload it
and we have the ball but you can see
that it disappears out in the space
because we don't have any collision
detector detection but at least it's
moving so we can see that
we have to add in some collision and
that's what we're going to do next
okay we're going to create a very
important thing for this game here um
well everything is important i think but
we need to have some collision detection
so that's why we're going to create a
class for that one and i'm going to
create this class
just in the root here src new file
that we call collision capital c
dot ts so we need some types
for our bricks paddle ball and canvas
canvas view so we import
brick from dot forward slash sprites
brick we import
the paddle from dot forward slash
sprites
paddle then we import
the ball from dot forward slash
sprites forward slash ball
and the last one is the canvas view
import
canvas view from
[Music]
dot forward slash view canvas view
and we're going to use these ones as
types and we don't create an instance of
the class
so we're using them as types and as i
told you before
when you create a class typescript will
interpret the type so you can use it as
a type
or you can use the class as it is just
yeah that's a regular class
so we export class
collision
like this we don't need to have a
constructor or anything
this class is just to kind of gather all
the colliding methods
in one class to give it a little bit of
a structure
and then you can easily also swap out
this class
if you have another class with another
collision detections
as long as the interface is the same and
the methods are called the same
you can swap it out to whatever you want
so we're gonna have three methods in
this one we're gonna have one that's
called
check ball collision
coalition like this
it's going to take in the ball it's
going to be able to type a ball
it's going to take in the paddle
paddle type and it needs the view and
it's going to be the canvas
view type and it's going to return
nothing so we specify it as
void right so first
one check
ball collision with paddle
so we have to check when the ball
collides with the paddle
and we can do that with a nice little if
statement if
we have the ball dot position dot x
plus the ball dot width if that one is
greater than the paddle
dot x so that's one thing we have to
check
we have double ampersands and we can
have another check here
ball dot post dot x if that one is
less than paddle dot pos
dot x plus paddle
width then we have a third one
ball dot post dot y plus
ball dot height if that one is equal to
the paddle
dot position dot y this one is a little
special because we're going to create a
more generic
collision detection function up here in
a second but
in this case we don't actually want the
ball to be able to hit the sides of the
paddle
because that will create a very strange
behavior
so if the y position is the same and
we're outside of the paddle
we're just gonna let it fall down and
the game will end
so that's why i have this little special
one with these three different checks
here
so if this is true gra then from the
ball we're gonna change
ah change y position no
change direction change y direction
right that's the first one
then to check ball collision
with walls so first we check the ball
movement
x constraints
and how do we do that well we have
another if statement if
ball.post.x if that one is greater than
view dot canvas dot
width minus the ball width or we have
double pipes
the ball dot pos dot x is lesser
than zero
then from the ball we're going to call
the change
x direction because then we know that we
collide with the wall to the left or to
the right
so then we change the x direction and
then we also need to check
ball movement y constraints
if ball.post.y
if that one is lesser than zero plus
ball dot height
then we call ball change y direction
so this is the canvas the y value is
going to be zero at the top so if we
leave the play field then we're going to
change the direction so if we collide
with the with the wall
at the top we don't have to check for
the wall at the bottom because we take
care of that
when we lose the game and the ball
disappears from that wall so it actually
should be able to disappear from that
wall
so that's why we don't do it here so
i think we can actually try this one out
so go back to our
index.ts file and up here
we're going to import the collision
clash class
import collision from
oops from dot forward slash
collision
so first in our start game we have to
create
the collision
we can do that here create the collision
instance cost collision
equal new collision
right so the only thing more we have to
do here is to send it along to our game
loop we do that last
collision and up here in our
game loop we have to take this one into
consideration also
so we add this one in
collision
and we use the collision as a type
we also have to add it in here to the
request
animation frame
collision like this
all right and what do we have to do here
in our game loop yeah well somewhere
maybe after we move the ball and paddle
from the collision we can call
the check ball collision we give it the
ball the paddle
and the view right
save it go back to our application
see what happens we click start
no it didn't work
and yeah i can see here now we need to
invoke this function also
so that's why so add this little
parenthesis here save the file go back
to our game reload it
start and there you have it it should
work
i actually it looks like it actually
collides
yeah i don't think we need the ball
height
on this one so i'm going to remove that
one go back to the game
again reload it click start yeah so you
don't need to add the ball height
and this looks great i think
we just need to create some little
functionality also for colliding with
the bricks
so i'm going to break this one
sources pause and i go back to my code
and inside the collision class we're
going to create
another method that we're going to use
for check
board collision
with bricks and we call it is colliding
brick it's going to take in the ball
with the ball type
the bricks it's going to be all the
bricks
so it's going to be able to type a brick
array an array with bricks
and that's everything we need it's going
to return a boolean
in this case and if you wonder
why i have separated this one out and
don't have it in this
collision method here that's because we
want to have this boolean to see if it's
true or false if we're colliding with a
brick we want to add to the score also
so that's why if this is true we can add
to the score so that's why i lifted it
out from that one
to have it in its own separate function
okay so we're going to send in all the
bricks the array with bricks and we have
the ball so we're going to loop through
these bricks and see if we are colliding
with anything
so let colliding we set this one
to false first then
we're going to run a for each loop
on the bricks if you don't want to use a
for each loop it's
a little bit faster to use a regular for
loop instead if you want to do that but
i don't think it matters in a small game
like this
so we have curly brackets and inside of
this for each loop we're going to do
something
so first we have to check if we're
actually colliding with this brick
so if this dot
is colliding
bricks and i'm going to create another
function for that instead of having it
inside of this one
maybe this one should be named
i think it's better to actually name
them the other way around so this one is
colliding bricks
this one is colliding brick
this one is going to take in a ball and
a brick
so up here above this one we're going to
create this one
is colliding brick
we have the ball of the type ball we
have the brick
of the type brick if you want you can
add in the paddle and you can use this
one
but you will get some strange behavior
as i said because then we're checking
all the edges on the paddle so yeah
it will probably work in most cases but
that's why i created this little special
one down below here instead
so i'm going to remove this for now or
not for now i'm going to remove it
and it can return a boolean and this if
statement that i'm going to create now
this is actually
a famous general relief statement for
checking collision between two boxes
and that's also why i have the ball as a
box because you won't be able to see
that it's actually colliding a little
bit outside of the circle
of the ball so that's why it's actually
a square and we can check the square
against the bricks that's also square
and that will make it a lot easier to do
a collision detection
so we have an if statement
if ball pos dot y
no dot x is less than brick dot pos
x plus brick dot width
that's the first one then we have the
ball dot
pause and also note that i have double
ampersands there
we have the ball.post.x
plus ball dot width if that one is
greater than the brick dot
pos dot x we have double ampersands
then we have the ball.post.y if that one
is less than brick
dot post.y plus brick dot
height and the last double ampersand
we check against ball dot post dot y
plus ball dot height
if that one is greater than the brick
dot post dot y
this will make sure that we check all
the sides on the box
on both the ball and the brick to see if
they collide
and then we return true
otherwise we're going to return false
we're not colliding
and that's why i specified the return
type as a boolean
all right so we can continue on we check
this here that's why i lifted it out
also so we don't have everything in the
same function here
so if this is colliding first we're
going to change the y direction of the
ball so ball dot
change y direction
now i make sure to call it also like
this with double parenthesis
then we're going to check if the brick
dot energy
if that one is down to one we're going
to remove the brick when we collide
because then it's going to be zero
and we're going to remove the brick from
the array so bricks dot splice
from the index and one step forward we
remove that brick
else brick dot
energy minus equal
one we remove one from the energy from
for the brick
and then we have this little left up
here colliding we're going to set that
one to
true
and then in the end
just below this one here we're going to
return
colliding so we're going to return this
variable here so it's going to be true
or false depending on if we collide so
these are the functions that we have
so save this file and we go back to the
index.ts file
and just below where we check the ball
collision
yeah maybe this one could have a better
name also because this is actually the
ball that we do a collision check on
also but all right i'm going to let it
be you can rename them to whatever you
want
this one i'm going to put in a const is
colliding
const colliding so from the collision
class
i'm gonna call is colliding bricks
with an s and we give it the ball
and the bricks
and we can then use this one because
this is going to return true or false
so we can use this one to actually
actually calculate some score also
so if colliding
so if we are colliding if this one
returns true we can rename this also
if colliding cons colliding brick
that will make it a little bit clearer
if colliding brick
we're going to add one to the score plus
equal one
and we also want to render it so view
dot draw score
and we give it the score
save the file go back
we load it just to be sure
start and you can see that it's
colliding
and these ones have more than one in
energy so that's why i have to hit them
more than one time
and there you can see they disappear
because the red and the green
only have one as energy
these ones the yellow ones have two i
think
so it seems to be working we have a
fully working game but
no not really fully we're fully working
we have to add in
that if we lose the game and also if we
win the game
and then we'll be finished with this one
right i'm gonna break it
we have one more thing to do before this
game is finished or at least finished in
this tutorial you can always build on it
and
make it more beautiful and add
functionality to it and hopefully you've
learned
some stuff about typescript so let's
move back to our code we're going to
create the game over and game
one functionality and for this one we're
going to be in the index index.ts
file and just below
here if colliding brick i'm going to
mark this with game over
when ball leaves play field
if ball dot plus dot y is greater than
view dot canvas dot height
so if the ball is outside of the canvas
we set the game over to true
then if game one
set game over no
set game over
and display win
so if bricks dot length
equals to zero so this is quite a simple
check i do
if we are won the game if we don't have
any bricks in the array
if the length is zero we know that we
won the games so this will stop the game
when you hit the last brick
and then we return and also call the set
game
win we give it the view
if you remember from the beginning of
this tutorial we have this
set game win where we display game one
and we set game over to false
and we also have one for game over
whoops for game over here
so this is for game win return
if game over and don't
run the request animation frame so this
is how we break this
infinity loop or it's not actually
infinite
infinitive because we can't break it but
it will continue on if
nothing else happens so if we win as we
return
here it's not gonna run this one here
and that's how we also do when we lose
the game
and we check if game over if that one is
true we're gonna return
and we also call the set game over like
this
we have to give it a view also and this
should be it
hopefully we have a fully working game
now
i think i'm gonna save it and try it out
so i reload it
i store it see what happens yeah it says
game over
i'm actually gonna play it through now
and i'm gonna skip here
a little bit and come back to you yeah
and there you have it you can see that
that i won the game now and it freezes
here on this image so if you don't want
that
you can do something else when you won
the game and clear the play field and
stuff like that
but at least it works hopefully this
gave an idea on how to create a game
like this with typescript
and i hope that you learned a lot about
typescript also
and as usual if you like my stuff make
sure to subscribe
on my channel and tell the world about
my
great great tutorials and hopefully i
see you in
another one